you demande d'excusés on serait
aujourd'hui pour une vidéo spéciale 500
mille abonnés alors écoutez j'ai plein
de choses à vous dire donc c'est pas si
on attaque de suite number one cette
figurine a été obtenu dans le coffret de
la route je n'en sais rien des choses un
peu plus intéressante est construite que
ça alors déjà je vous remercie vraiment
tous et toutes pour me suivre sur
youtube vous êtes 500 milles à la moitié
d'un million je fais ce vous rendez
compte c'est un truc énorme et évinça le
chah pourra vous dire je pense à un truc
à d'autres occasions mais bon ça c'est
obtenus sur deux ans et demi faut pas
rêver on crée pas une chaîne youtube
elle n'a pas déjà direct d'office cinq
cent mille abonnés bouffe et du coup
voilà on a gravi vraiment du chemin on a
on a fait au début vraiment des choses
dans les jeux pour ceux qui me suivent
depuis le début il y en a forcément
qu'ils seront plus début on a vraiment
commencé par du colosse qui on est passé
par pas mal de jeu puis j'ai commencé à
faire de lire l affaire ce petit concept
de l'intro yaël avant la vidéo etc
et voilà aujourd'hui on en est à faire
pas mal grl bon j'aime et phase 1 des
fois je préfère les rênes des fois les
jeux le fait est que en ce moment vous
aurez remarqué que la par exemple depuis
vendredi soir dernier j'ai pas sorti de
vidéos
c'est pas que j'en ai marre de youtube
que voilà j'ai plus la flamme que
j'avais avant et cetera pas du tout bien
au contraire lui juste trop envie de
faire mais vu mais je ne peux pas
ah mais je peux pas parce qu'en fin
d'année j'ai un truc qui s'appelle le
bac
ouais voilà faut bien travailler surtout
que pendant l'année j'ai un petit peu
mis de côté les études pour les vidéos
du coup voilà je me dis bon je veux au
moins essayer d'avoir mon bac c'est quoi
ces deux semaines à travailler à mettre
de côté les vidéos puis une semaine de
des preuves et ensuite on réattaque
d'office et on s'éclate
donc voilà ça c'est juste pour expliquer
un petit peu la baisse de vidéo ces
derniers temps sur ma chaîne qu'il faut
pas s'affoler c'est normal de toute
façon j'ai quand même essayé d'en fermer
pendant ces deux semaines de révision
même c'est ce n'est qu'une par semaine
par exemple c'est quand même une vidéo
je suis dégoûté parce qu'en plus j'ai
pas mal c'est un peu saoulant bref je
suis là sinon pour vraiment bas vous
remercier encore une fois vous dire que
c'est un petit peu un petit peu un rêve
qui se réalise pas ce que comme j'ai pu
dire dans pas mal d'interviews bon chez
que ce mot fait gros beauf la star
planétaire internationale qui se prepare
view et alors c'est pas du tout le cas
jusque voilà avant je trouvais a en fait
quand j'ai commencé ma chaîne youtube ya
deux ans que j'ai commencé il ya deux
ans et demi il se trouve que voilà
j'étais le petit luca qui était en
seconde qui avait plein de la clé un
casque de cheveux etc et j'étais
passionné de jeu et puis je voyais à
l'époque voilà déjà quelques vidéos sur
youtube et je me disais bon boulot si
lucas tu passes ton temps à s'affirmer à
jouer donc pourquoi pas faire des vidéos
comme eux
pourquoi pas essayer de chez soi je peux
toutefois pas essayé de faire des choses
comme le voilà de de t'occuper tout
simplement d'être productif tout
simplement
et au final je me suis lancée voilà au
début on s'est un peu pourri etc
puis j'ai eu la fameuse chance après
quelques mois de faire une vidéo et
quartz ex m'a pas mal booster puis
ensuite les choses se sont enchaînées
vite avec les outils de squeeze et
l'appliquent le muscle avec plein de
choses au final on en est là avec
cyprien carrément et d'ailleurs j'ai
vraiment eu beaucoup de chance qu'ils me
jacky me choisisse pour pour son projet
de chaîne gaming d'ailleurs sur laquelle
on rigole bien on rigole on rigole fort
l on mange bien aussi des conneries tout
l'aprem parce que oui contre de vidéos
ça se gavent de créer ma de pick-up voit
la petite parenthèse et voilà
actuellement je suis carrément la ligue
2 avec cyprien qui est quand même un des
meilleurs francophones vraiment vraiment
haut placées entre guillemets si je peux
dire est honoré moi je suis là un petit
rôle d'ado dans ma chambre
le média allez on fait les milieux et
puis voilà je pense que maintenant de
toute façon il ya plein de gens qui
veulent faire des vidéos n'ont pas non
pas pour l'argent nous pas pour pour
faire comme toutes fins il y en a qui
font ça pour faire comme tout le monde
mais on a aussi qui font ça pour la même
raison fonds à l'époque c'est à dire
qu'ils adorent les jeux et qu'ils ont
envie de faire avec cette passion ils
ont envie de faire quelque chose d'aller
plus loin que jouer tout simplement et
voilà ils veulent proposer du contenu
aux gens les divertir et sales usa eux
mêmes à construire quelque chose autour
de autour de leur passion pour les jeux
et puis voilà ben moi ça a démarré comme
ça et je pense que maintenant
bah j'ai eu de la chance c'est eux les y
avait encore eu cette vague immense de
youtube heures et voilà c'est quand même
génial dans la fin voilà je me retrouve
quand même 500 milles un foutu demi
million d'abonnés retiendrait pas dans
ma [ __ ] de vie les chambres donc c'est
assez dingue assez dingue et et j'en
perds mes mots car avant je me suis dit
[ __ ] j'ai été dégoûté parce que
j'avais vraiment une super idée pour les
ponts pour faire une vidéo 500 mille
abonnés et par manque de temps à cet
aprem je vaux studio france tu veux
qu'il aimait faire un ballet vidéo pour
supra gamine
et après j'aurais plus trop le temps
peut-être ce week-end j'ai essayé de
faire ça quand même mais voilà ça faut
comprendre qu'une vidéo ça fait quand
même pas mal de temps à faire il ya le
prêt relais et vidéo sur les jeunes on
s'est vite c'est vite fait mais voilà
j'ai envie d'approfondir la chose n'est
pas faire de simples entre guillemets 2
sur les jeux où il ya le gameplay où je
parle où je sais plus trop quoi dire je
suis pas un renfort en fait ce calme
comme je fais là d'ailleurs voilà
j'avais envie de faire un truc spécial
mais je peux pas le faire je suis
vraiment dégoûté et puis j'avais
d'autres idées deux autres idées aussi
majeure que je pouvais faire aussi pour
ses 500 milles qui étaient sympas et
voilà encore une fois je peux pas je me
retrouve à faire ça j'espère que vous ne
m'en voudrez pas parce que c'était pas
vraiment mon habitude pour célébrer un
chiffre important d'abonnés sachant
classé 500 mais c'est énorme de faire
une vidéo juste en face tookam vous
parlez ne vous inquiétez pas on se
rattrapera après le bac c'est promis
d'ailleurs je vous souhaite de bien
réviser si vous avez le bac ou des
partiels je sais plus s'il ya encore à
se damner le 5 juin j'ai pas s'il ya pas
jamie des partielles ou quoi en tout cas
le bac c'est du 17 au 22 juin donc vous
penserez à moi et le brevet je crois que
c'est début juillet me semble je sais
plus peut-être tout fin juin enfin moi
en tout cas révisez bien et voilà mettez
un petit peu les jeux de côté pour tout
ce qui est à tous qui examen diplôme ou
quoi en un mois on peut rattraper une
année même si on pense que ce n'est pas
faisable si c'est faisable sur ma peine
quelques bases mais voilà quand moi
j'arrivais en cours et que je faisais
des et que j'écrivais le script de
podcasts et d'un troll irl bon tu dis
que j'ai tenu bon quoi donc voila et
puis
figeac pas dire donc voilà c'est une
catastrophe absolue enfin bon voilà
aujourd'hui je remercie que toi qui as
garé cette vidéo je te tutoie part du
groupe quasi eux parce que tu commentes
les vidéos tu mets des petits pouces
verts qui me disent oh [ __ ] cette
vidéo a bien marché on va tout de suite
dans le genre là tu m'envoies des
messages pour me dire ah j'ai pas trop
aimé ça j'aime bien ça toi car cette
vidéo j'adore j'adore tout ce que tu
fais pour moi pas tu poses aussi que
vous serez nombreux à me demander qu'est
ce que ça fait d'avoir cinq cent mille
abonnés eh ben j'ai envie de vous dire
que vu qu'on commet 10 ans gravit les
échelons petit à petit c'est pas comme
si d'un coup on passé de 2000 abonnés à
500 mille bombes
c'est vraiment voit les choses arrivent
et on voit que ça monte etc et puis au
final on n'est pas là je vois tout le
temps à regarder notre nombre d'abonnés
tout le temps à faire si à faire ça
certes je pense que la majorité des
youtuber regard chaque jour si là sa
dernière vidéo a bien marché si elle a
plu au coi pour anticiper un petit peu
la réaction des gens parce que oui on
fait ce qu'on aime
mais bon à un moment je suis d'accord
avec ceux qui disent à fait des vidéos
pour toi fais des vidéos sur ce que tu
aimes maintenant si j'ai envie de faire
une chaîne maquillage je parle souvent
d'accord sur fait que ça fout plaira me
faut s'abstenir de certaines choses
quand même mais à moins dans l'ensemble
généralement j'ai toujours fait ce que
j'avais envie de faire
et heureusement pour moi ça s'appelait
en majorité eh ben c'est une chance mais
bon je pense que tous les youtube heures
obtiennent leur communauté à partir de
ce qu'ils font donc forcément il aime
parce que ce qu'ils font quoi tout
simplement
pour pas venir en faisant c'est de la
merde mais je m'abonne mais maintenant
tu fais des choses comme moi je l'avoué
ok c'est non pour la route bougeait mec
à quoi bon genre femme en voile à
écouter les gens on va arrêter les
remerciements et les vidéos super comme
ça je vous remercie encore une fois de
plus éternellement vous réalisez un
petit rêve d'un ado de de 14 ans 15 ans
qui voulait faire des vidéos et monter
un petit peu de une chaîne youtube ou
une organisation
et puis bah on se retrouve bientôt dans
des vidéos mégaphone là c'était un petit
peu la mine ou de confession avec
squeeze on va l'appeler comme ça les
vidéos la minute confessions les 15 500
mille abonnés et puis on se retrouve
bientôt dans une nouvelle vidéo j'espère
en tout cas que le manque de vidéo ces
temps ci vous troublera pas vous et
votre santé mentale mais en tout cas je
vous invite juste à regarder des
anciennes vidéos dans la description je
mettrai la playlist tomb raider donc de
terrible aventure sur tomb raider la
playlist des moments débile avec squeeze
la playlist des podcasts la playlist des
vidéos diverses et variées et c'est des
défis de squeeze vous pourrez allez vous
marier à regarder tout ça parce que
parce que là on va là il y aura pas
vraiment de nouvelle vidéo géniale c'est
aussi même si j'espérais quand même d'en
faire
donc voilà on se retrouve bientôt dans
une nouvelle vidéo on va essayer ce week
end si c'est faisable
et puis encore merci à tout le monde je
vous remercie vraiment encore encore et
encore et puis portez vous bien essayer
de réussir vos examens geek et bien
amusez vous bien
et voilà que tout le monde pousse et à
bientôt
non du suspense à bientôt dans quoi dans
une nouvelle fois médine ou au mais
[ __ ] mais c'est nul en fait un bep
compta quoi ce bordel la rn8 défoncé